was born with a unique physique
including muscles that are eight times
denser than the muscles of a regular
human this gives her superhuman physical
strength and endurance and it allows her
to deliver incredibly powerful attacks
mitsuri is also unbelievably flexible
and her combat technique incorporates
challenging acrobatic Maneuvers that
most of her opponents simply aren't
expecting the unique design of her
special nitrogen blade Makes Her Moves
even more unconventional and
unpredictable mitsuri's Katana features
a custom design that is completely
different from the swords used by other
demon Slayers her sword blade is very
long thin and flexible and it functions
more like a sharp whip than a normal
sword she is the only one who can use
this Sword without hurting herself if
you want to know more about mitri's
unique powers her tragic backstory and
which lucky guy she ends up with at the
end check out my full mitsuri video link
in the description and in the pinned
comment